oh yes the time has to come because
bowties are cool alright folks we
continue with series 5 and yep complete
outfit change not quite
screen accurate the coat isn't quite
right but it gets by and also it is a it
is a correct feds as the doctor wears
cuz his doesn't have the tassel actually
really bugs me when I see people
cosplaying the doctor and they've got
the Fez with the tassel his did not have
a tassel when he had one but anyways
alright the Beast below this is a bit of
an odd one and I don't think I've talked
about it outside of actually having it
on my list of worst episodes that Steven
Moffat wrote although it should be said
that much like when I did my list of
worst episode that Russell T Davies
wrote most of the bottom end of that
list were not actually bad episodes they
were just bad by the standards that they
set for themselves as writers and beasts
below having rewatched it now it's
better than I was giving it credit for
but only in certain areas a lot of the
things that I have issues with very much
I feel pretty vindicated about this is a
bit of an odd beast of an episode beast
anyways there's a in many ways this
feels like a summation of the
differences between Moffat and Davies
possibly even more so than 11th hour was
because what this episode is is
mechanically and by mechanics I mean the
plot mechanics is very precise and
everything has a point and a purpose and
it rings very true
narrative playing out perspective
emotionally it doesn't quite hit all the
notes so the machinations of the plot
work very well the emotional resonance
of the plot is a little bit more uneven
which isn't a lot of ways an inversion
from Davies who would sometimes play a
little bit fast and loose with his
plotting but would usually really
resonate with the emotional end of
things so what do I mean by what I'm
even saying well there's a lot of things
going on here that I feel like they they
are there simply because the mechanics
of the plot function better with them
there but there is emotional weirdness
with them there so this is the episode
that is set on spaceship or I believe
it's actually Starship UK so at some
point in time the entirety of the United
came actually every nation but you know
it's a British show so we're gonna
follow the UK they loaded their entire
population onto a spaceship and you know
they modeled it as best as they could
after their country set off into space
because the earth was no longer
habitable so we open up with this
classroom and a young boy who got a zero
on a test and when he tries to use the
lift a pit opens up beneath him and he's
gone and we get a really interesting
lead in with all this because amy has
her whole communication with the doctor
he's like oh no I don't interfere but
then she sees him going up and talking
to or at least observing and starting to
try and figure out a young girl who's
crying like so you never interfere
unless children are crying and sort of
immediately poking holes in the rules
that the doctor says he follows again
kind of picking up from what I said last
time with the fact that she she kind of
has his number a little bit and she sees
through him a bit more
usually you'd have from someone who is
really only just starting out to travel
with him and there's a lot of thematic
through lines here that again work on a
mechanical plot level so like the
connection between that and then what
happens later with Amy realizing that
the star whale is effectively like the
doctor that's a good solid thematic
through line but it's also reinforces
than is needed and it softens the
emotional impact because it's actually
very well cut at the tail end of this
because you know spoilers that like
these reviews are intended you know for
people who've seen the thing at least
once if you haven't realized that by now
I there you go so at the tail end of it
when amy has Liz ten abdicate and you
know she explains why she knew the star
whale wouldn't abandon them and she
likens it to the doctor through you know
just looking at him while she's talking
about this saying it was the last of its
kind and it was kind and it did not want
children in pain and then the very next
scene is her saying that literally the
exact same thing again directly to his
face and saying doesn't that something
around like yeah yeah I know you you you
made your point you made your emotional
point last scene you don't have to make
it again what and then there's little
odd things like so the child that I
mentioned at the beginning and it gets
said that the star whale won't eat
children now what's always bugged me
about that is the fact that okay so the
star world doesn't eat the children good
except that that means that this
government is still kidnapping children
and taking them from the families and
never giving them back because everyone
thinks that these children who disappear
are gone forever so why aren't you like
so that the argument is is that the
those who do not contribute to society
get fed to the way
like okay but if it's not gonna eat the
children anyway why don't you just set
that to kick in like at an age when the
thing actually will eat them and you
know like remove children from their
friends and family who now think that
they're dead
like why would you do that it rings very
emotionally untrue for you know for the
this whole thing it the fact that nobody
calls them on that that they are
kidnapping children but it's
mechanically necessary because amy has
to link the fact that the star whale
will not eat the children with the fact
that the doctor responded to a crying
child so mechanically plot mechanics it
needs to be there but it's weird and
wacky and doesn't get properly address
on an emotional level because it's still
really screwed up when you look at it
through that perspective but that's just
sort of a an easy go to another thing
and I've mentioned this before I feel
like for the doctors blow up at Amy for
that to ring emotionally true this
episode couldn't be episode 2 because
the hurt of him saying to her after I
leave here you're done and I'm not
traveling with you again for that to
really hit the way that it should
because that should hurt even if we know
like she's not leaving but that should
be a hurtful moment but this is their
very first outing it's like he's got a
media buyer's remorse as opposed to he
feels betrayed by someone he trusted
there needed more time for that bond to
be there so that doesn't land properly
because this is only the second episode
again the emotional truth doesn't quite
work but again plot mechanics is really
good and some of the emotional stuff
works Karen Gillan gives a phenomenal
performance in terms of her realization
of what happens in delivering all of
that and though the just the the
delivery she gives you know after having
seen the video
that I I kind of wish the the video is
the not the vide the the episode is kind
of making multiple points in terms of
the exploitation of in this case an
animal but you know of a resource but
also about democracy and I I mean they
actually complement each other sometimes
when things have you know more than one
thing going on they don't always mix and
they do in this case but I kind of wish
that we could have dug a little bit more
into a democratic system that allows
people to vote in their own
self-interest but then absolves them
from it by allowing them to not remember
what it was that they agreed to I feel
like there's a lot of really interesting
satire and and really picking a part of
the political process and the ways in
which people vote that isn't quite done
and again I think part of that lends
itself to the fact that I feel like
there the fact that they throw anyone
who protests to the beast like that
doesn't quite that doesn't quite click
for me to that seems like wait wait what
because it feels like it undermines some
of the themes of well this is the
reality that they choose oh they didn't
choose that will kill them like that the
the level of sort of police state 'no
seems weird and wonky because it's
trying to make points about the people
have the right to know and they do in
fact choose to do this and the fact that
well no but they're also kind of force
so it's undermining its own points a
little bit to that extent I should I
should mention Liz 10 it's a pretty
solid performance overall the the
character unfortunately feeds into
something that at this point I've now
talked about which is the characters
growing
reputation within the show and I'm kind
of of two minds about it because it
hasn't quite got not a handi yet but
this is another step in it heading that
way the fact that the monarch of Britain
of the UK knows that the doctor exists
knows what to look for and immediately
seeks his help when he turns up now like
it's one of those things like it's hard
for me to pinpoint the exact moment that
the doctors reputation got big enough
that it's like nits not working for me
anymore
and I don't know if this is the point
but this is definitely a step closer to
the point because on the one hand okay
for the royal family oh that makes sense
he keeps interacting with the royal
family
over and over and over again we've seen
him you know just in the course of new
who we've seen him interact with
Elizabeth and with Victoria and so like
it makes sense that it becomes a royal
family you know thing that they sort of
pass along keep an eye out for this guy
except that I'm not sure that it adds
much to the narrative and I don't like
how it continues to expand out the
doctors reputation even if at this point
we're limiting it to the royal family I
think it would have been enough for a
Liz tend to take note of the fact like
he did something with the water he knows
something's wrong I want to get his take
and I want to see if he'll help not
because he's the doctor but because she
needs allies that would have been enough
knowing who he is
I don't think actually adds a lot to the
story
try think what else the smilers are a
very cool design but they're kind of a
placeholder villain there's a fair
number of those in the Moffitt era the
whisper men later on down the line come
to mind as well there are a fair number
of basically henchmen placeholder
villains who had actually very cool
designs but by the end don't actually do
all that much and you know despite my
reservations the per about some of the
the way the the story pans out on an
emotional level it is plot
mechanics-wise quite well
assembled and put together in terms of
anything that's there that feels off for
me I can't knock it on a on a plot
progression level because it is
necessary in some way fits for the most
part and the performances are all solid
Liz 10 is very fun Matt Smith is really
already he's into this part very well
and his rapport with Karen Gillan is
great I do think she gives the best
performance this particular episode but
it's really good in the end the idea of
Starship UK is pretty cool in and of
itself so I do think there's a lot that
is good about this episode but there's
enough that doesn't quite line up that
it's still a yeah I don't think it's one
of Moffitt's better or better once it's
not it is not bad but it it isn't quite
firing on all cylinders it's firing on
about half 2/3 of the cylinders I
suppose would be the way that I would
put it now will probably fly better if
they stop torturing the pilot and with
that reference we'll wrap this one up
the Beast below you've seen it would you
think about it whatever you thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about a whole bunch of stuff
to do because there's buttons and links
you can help me get more costumes diadem
I actually have had this for years this
wasn't even bought with patreon money
but that does help me cover my bills and
help them prove the channel and do all
that kind of stuff plus you know
subscribe like both those things are
helpful there's other things to check
out beside give them a click or don't ya
don't have to because at the end of the
day folks
you're the council I'm just running the
meeting so until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]